you also [ __ ] with a lot of rappers so
some of these these pickup games you'll
be having are like
the who's who of hip-hop running up and
down the court for sure
now the the guy who i have always heard
now i've seen quavo play cuevo you know
obviously he hooped for that bleacher
report [ __ ] and did his thing
but the guy who i always hear is the
best is coal
yeah hands down it's j so so you're
saying colt out of all the hip-hop
artists rappers it's j cole j cole's the
best and so
uh yeah so you know before kovy we we
worked for like
six seven straight months i mean j cole
just uh
working on his shot working you know he
would religiously i think he'd go to the
studio during the day and at night
we would work out like every night and
then he started playing in the black ops
nba runs so i'd be nine very good nba
players and he'd be on the court
and he was playing really good and uh
now he can really hope that's not even
close as far as like that's some good
rappers
that are good but he could like hang
with the play overseas right now he
could yeah he's
he's worked on it and he's good yeah
when someone puts that much time and
effort like you said for
like for however many months they must
be serious about trying to get better at
basketball yeah
there's been rumors that he might be
trying to make a run
to get in the league is that something
that he's got that that you know that
like might be maybe on his goal list
yeah um i can't speak for him maybe i
guess we'll see
i mean the pistons man you know we'll
see thank you i think there's a few
teams that could literally use anybody
and the pistons are one of them
yeah no i wouldn't be surprised if it
happens but
it hasn't happened since master p he's
better than master p
he's best i've seen the mess i've seen
master p clips
has is he better than any nba players
you've trained
you don't got to tell me who no so i
would say so
let's be honest so if he were to be a
pro he'd be a shooter right
he's a better shooter than some of the
guys for sure
for sure so he'd be a spot up shooter
he'd be a shooter j.j reddick
yeah he'd be that type of thing except
jj reddick like was really good with
moving out the ball
i think he'd just be more of like a spot
up shooter cole would be the he would be
the uh
i'm trying to think who else he'd be
kyle korver in the corner he had he had
six seven game winners in the black ops
games and like the nba guys would be so
pissed like
every time he'd do it because they were
really trying and he'd be hitting game
winners
his ice in his veins wow that's crazy